Gửa thu hưởng thải lan thạch sình xin à vật ra, ông chầm con gái khi giời nhà tụ sau tham tháng bị giám giữ.
Giám mềm một tháng năm, ông thạch sình vài mì sảo tuổi được phong thích trước thời hạn,
khỏi nhà tụ trong tầm gần lòng brem ở bằng cáo, với điều kiện phải đào thiết bị giám sát địa từ trong bún tháng quán trễ của lại.
Ông là một trong hơn tám chăm năm với tụ nhân, được ra tụ trước hạn trong đận này.
Tháng chăm vừa ủng hộ mặt áo đó, trong đó có con gái ông, gửu thu tưởng về thông tàn xin à vật ra thập chung trước nhà tụ để chào lòng nông.
Ông thạch sình tình dự chức thu tưởng từ năm hành yên không trong lệ mốt, trước khi bị lật lộ trong cuộc đạo chính quân sự năm hành yên không trong lệ sấu.
Tháng tám năm hành yên không trong hài bà, ông chờ về thái lan sau hơn một thập kỳ lưu vong.
khi về nước, ông bị két án tám năm tụ vì tụi làm quyền nhưng được ẩn sát xuất quan một năm.
Tụi nhân, ông chì ở tụi vài dơ trước khi được chuyển đến bệnh vệnh vì đau tìm và tức nước.
Ông được ẩn sát sau sấu tháng năm trong phòng VIP của bệnh vệnh.
Tháng chiến năm hành yên không trong hài lâm, tụi án tối cao thái lan phán quyết, việc chuyển không thặc xin từ nhà tụi sang bệnh vệnh năm hành yên không trong hài bà, là trái pháp luật và yêu cầu ông quay lại nhà tụ để chấp hành bản án mốt năm tụi.